you're a graduate of the
navy fighter weapons school yeah i am
better known as top gun let me
let me ask the most ridiculous question
how realistic is the movie top gun
so it's funny we used to joke and a
friend of mine who was a top cut
instructor
uh said this there's two things in the
in the original top gun that are true
that are very realistic one there is a
place called top gun
and number two is they do fly airplanes
there
other than that uh you know i went
through in 97
uh class 497 and there's actually a log
of every single person that's went
through kind of like
seal training you know there's a list so
people because there's a lot of posers
out there i was a navy seal
no you weren't well i went to top gun
you can actually go to top gun and
matter of fact
just to get a top gun patch the real
patch
you have to have gone there so a lot of
the patches you see
uh running around are not real there's
the real ones are controlled
the people that make them uh honor that
and when you go in they look up your
name
if you want to get one they look up your
name you just tell them they go okay
here and i'll sell them to you if you
are not on the list
you ain't get no patch because it is
it's it's it's a pretty big deal
to go through but it's for me uh
probably the best experiences of flying
uh because everyone there is extremely
competent
it's very very challenging
but it's what we all signed up to do so
it's
uh it's just the entire group that is
when you want to be that you know that
level
you know where you go everyone really
cares and everyone really wants to be
good
is it competitive like what was it in
the movie or no
it's when you go through it's you know
it's
if anything it's more of the students
you know and then there's the instructor
side
and the instructor sides are really you
know they're guys that you know
they just chose to stay up and fallon
and it's extremely
uh difficult job because they have
they have a very small tolerance for
not being good uh so they're briefs the
guys when they give a lecture so
let's just say there's a fighter
employment lecture which is one of the
hardest ones it takes about two days to
give the fighter employment lecture
the guy who gives the lecture goes
through multiple what they call a murder
boards where he's scrutinized by his
peers and he practices
by the time they actually stand in front
of a class
they pretty much have their 250
powerpoint slides memorized
and they don't even turn around they
just click and they know them in order
and they repeat the same thing over it's
and it's standardized so they're
extremely extremely standardized when
you go through the school and there's a
reason for that
because what they're doing is they're
training so when you come out of top gun
you're called a strike fighter weapons
and tactics instructor
okay so you're sfti when you come out of
that
your job is to go usually to one of the
weapons schools on the east or west
coast and train the fleet squadrons and
then you
visit the squadrons and train and do
upgrade rides and all that so
there's a there's a reason that they are
extremely
uh particular when you go through the
course it's
it is literally one of the best things
and it's not it's not a rank based thing
because think oh navy
you can come in as a you know like a an
04 lieutenant
commander the lieutenants the hierarchy
well it used to be i don't know how it
is exactly today but i imagine it's the
same
the hierarchy is actually based on
seniority at the school not necessarily
ranked so when the
tactical decisions are made which are
based on fact and and
trying things out in the fallon ranges
uh
they set this the top x number of folks
that have been there seniority wise
is and i mean time wise are the ones
that actually make the decision and when
the door
you may not agree but when the door
opens and everyone comes out
from the staff they all speak the same
language
it's and it has to be that way which is
why the school has been so effective
since it was founded
so it's just a it's an incredible group
of individuals
so there's a bar of excellence that uh
that the instructors demand well very
much so and they're held to it
so it's not a hey i'm now an instructor
so i can do what i want
there is a standard and they have to
live up to that standard
they have to and i mean every moment of
every day
uh so if they go someplace if they go
from fallon and they come down and do
they're called site visits where they
come down and they'll come to la moore
california which is where the west coast
fighter wing is at for the navy
and they go around and start flying
sorties with the fleet squadrons
to kind of pass on some of that
knowledge that's that same high level of
standard it's they can't just drop your
guard
because you wear the top gun patch and
people know that and they wear light
blue shirts so it's pretty easy to
identify them when they're out there
and you know and then everyone else
who's been through the school including
them have the patch on their sleeve
so there's a standard that's expected
when you come out of there
you